hey remember when the libs told you that
the covid vaccine was totally effective
and if you got it you would not get the
virus and then like five minutes later
they told you that you needed a booster
shot
and then like five minutes after that
they told you that you needed another
booster shot well some new science has
just dropped and it turns out that now
according to Kamala Harris
you're going to need to get one of those
super effective covid shots every single
year quote one shot once a year that's
all most people will need to stay
protected from covid year long make a
plan to get your shot that's what the
vice president said three days ago
but then
two days ago so that's just uh one day
after Kamala said it the Secretary of
Health and Human Services Xavier Becerra
announced that actually you're going to
need to get six covid shots every year
quote if it's been over two months since
your last dose uh quote make a plan to
get one now
now that guidance was of course two days
ago so if the number of necessary shots
has kept pace multiplying by six every
day that means presumably as of today
that we all will need to get 216 fauci
ouchies per year to mitigate the
symptoms of covid by tomorrow one
suspects that number will be 1296 and
within a week they'll just hook us all
up to an IV to Stave off the mild cough
as has been the case from the beginning
of kovid the public health authorities
are contradicting themselves constantly
but the one thing that remains certain
is that we all have to trust them
implicitly do exactly as they say and
never question a thing I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Frank who says
the fact that murderers hate pedophiles
more than the Democrats do tells you
everything you need to know about the
current state of the party that's that's
a pretty good point I had not thought of
that before the pedophiles are much much
safer in the company of elected
prominent Democrats than they are in the
company of murderers and all sorts of
terrible people in prison you'd be much
better if you're a pedophile you'd do
much much better to hang out with
Democrats than the murderers Democrats
could make U.S state senator in
California for instance I don't know I'm
just thinking off the top of my head
it's really good by the way whether
you're in prison whether you're out of
prison but I know people you know in
prison they work out a lot you know what
else are you going to do you got a lot
of free time on your hands well the rest
of us who are outside the clink we
should work out too we should get our
bodies in order we should get heart
healthy we should check out
Echelon Fitness right now text Knowles
to 81 81 81 I've been working too hard
this year I've been working way too hard
to bring you this show every single day
you know what I haven't been doing
enough I haven't been working out that's
right I want to get in shape but I don't
have time to get to the gym that is why
Echelon Fitness brings the gym home to
me Echelon Fitness is the affordable way
to get workout equipment a workout
community and an instructor's motivation
right in the comfort
and privacy of your own home Echelon
fitness's Connected app
provides thousands of Live And on-demand
classes with great music to keep you
moving you can work at any time day or
night their full range of affordable
workout equipment includes stationary
bikes smart rowers Sleek Fitness screens
and an auto folding treadmill these are
all connected to the echelon fitness app
for The Full Experience Around the Clock
classes including full body workout
programs will keep you coming back one
membership covers a family of five I
absolutely love love my Echelon for a
limited time our audience can get a free
bike or rowing machine with a 24-month
membership
to get your free bike or rower text
Knowles kwles to 81 81.81 that is
Knowles kwles to 81 8181 to claim your
free bike or rowing machine text Knowles
kwles to 81 8181 message and data rates
may apply C terms for details
so we have to trust the science the
science is always right the scientists
always know exactly what they're talking
about it's funny that Kamala Harris and
Xavier Becerra are making this
announcement right now two days after I
gave the speech at Franciscan University
about how science is totally fake and
you can find that speech in its entirety
at the yaf YouTube channel it's it's
just obviously totally fake it's
obviously just shooting in the dark and
yet they insist we have to believe
whatever they say at any given moment
and if you contradict it at all or raise
any questions then you're spreading
dangerous misinformation you're
basically a murderer and you need to be
de-platformed but then they contradict
themselves pretty dramatically within 24
hours
the difference between well forget for a
moment that they told us get the shot
and you're good
period now we're being told now you have
to have multiple shots
now they're saying you're gonna have to
get a shot every single year and then 24
hours later they say you're actually
you're gonna have to get six shots a
year
that's a pretty a pretty big difference
okay and there's nothing new here the
public health authorities have always
been a little bit dodgy and they remain
dodgy and they remain dodgy even about
their own dodgy history there was an
announcement from Rachelle wolenski
Rachelle wolenski is the head of the CDC
who throughout covet has gotten a whole
lot of things wrong who told you that if
you got the vaccine you would not catch
covid then what happened a lot of people
did catch covid and then Rochelle
wolenski tried to retcon the guidance
and say no no we weren't talking about
how you couldn't catch covet or spread
covet we were just saying that actually
you know uh it'll it'll mitigate some of
your symptoms but that that is not what
they said so Rachelle valenski who's got
a pretty checkered track record right
now she announces
quote this year marks the 50th
anniversary
of the end of the Tuskegee syphilis
study tomorrow I will be joined by
colleagues and public health leaders as
we honor the 623 African-American men
their suffering and sacrifice and our
commitment to ethical research and
practice
come again could you explain what we're
celebrating tomorrow because she's
referring to the Tuskegee syphilis study
that's better known as the Tuskegee
experiments the Tuskegee experiments
started in 1932 when the U.S Public
Health Service conspired with the
Tuskegee Institute to create a fake
medical program and the fake medical
program was purporting to treat people
with syphilis instead they administered
a bunch of dangerous chemicals and
procedures to hundreds and hundreds of
black male participants who had no idea
that they were being treated as Lab Rats
and this went on for decades only in the
1970s did the government actually cop to
the conspiracy and pay out 10 million
dollars plus Lifetime Health benefits to
the men that it exploited so no it it
wasn't just some ordinary syphilis study
it was actually keeping effective
treatments away from these black guys
and giving them all sorts of chemicals
to see what that sort of thing would do
and those black guys did not make a
sacrifice they were sacrificed or at the
very least they were exploited by
corrupt and cynical Public Health
officials
and the craziest part of the
announcement to me
is not the the language is pretty wild
here because they're they're clearly uh
painting with with a Rosy brush what
actually took place
but what's so amazing is the fact that
they they continue to try to cover this
sort of thing up and celebrate it and
frame it as a you know great research
and wonderful sacrifice is it tells you
they'll do it again these people have
not reformed at all the only reason they
had to cop to the the Tuskegee
experiments in the first place is that
it was just it was exposed and they had
to say okay yeah okay we've sort of been
doing this thing for a while and they
remain so cynical about the whole thing
what do they do today so it's I always
think about this with the cias and other
government agencies when they conducted
all sorts of
extraordinarily unethical uh projects
and experiments in the 20th century
think of MK Ultra you know testing out
drugs psych drugs on unwitting
participants and all all manner of
conspiracies and then today we're just
supposed to believe yeah but then they
stopped doing all of that
yes it's true the government perpetrated
all sorts of wicked wicked conspiracies
in the past but yeah no we don't we
don't do that anymore one day we all
just they just decided to stop
oh yeah okay cool that's great well if
you believe that I have got a bridge in
Brooklyn to sell you I've got a bag from
Balenciaga to sell you if you believe
that talking about experiments and
conspiracies so a friend of mine tipped
me off to this last night
few other people seem to have noticed it
as well we've covered for a couple of
weeks now the Balenciaga
weird child porn referencing s m
featuring advertisement campaigns that
they were running a few weeks ago and
then there was this really weird
phenomenon on Google Translate
where if you typed in Bal n c AGA into
Google translate you said from Latin to
English
it just said do what you want
which is very strange because if you
just typed in ba it would say ba because
bar is not a Latin word Len
Len it's not a Latin word so there's
there was no translation c c oga
but then you type in ba Len C AGA it
says do what you want doesn't make sense
that's not what that means in Latin and
it happens to be the first commandment
of the satanists do what thou Wilt
should be the entirety of the law as
formulated by Aleister Crowley so anyway
a friend of mine last night said what
happens if you add another a to the ball
so it's not Bots ball meaning probably
the most prominent demon that's been
worshiped in human history
so you type in ball lowercase and you
get as an answer lowercase ball
because there's no there's no
Latin word ball that would mean
something different in English then you
type in NC
again you get NC because NC is not a
Latin word AGA you get act okay so there
could be an English rendering of AGA in
Latin
but then you type in ball b-a-a-l like
the demon NC Aga
and the translation on Google translate
into English is Bal is the king
and it gets even weirder all of a sudden
it capitalizes the b in ball when you
just do ball
is as a standalone word Latin to English
it keeps it lowercase
when you type in ball and see AGA it
translates it to a capital B like the
proper noun of a demon ball is the king
it goes without saying that is not what
that statement means in Latin so what
does this mean that this happens what
does this mean that these two really
really weird translations come out in
Google Translate that don't actually
translate the the words from Latin and
it'll suggest sometimes different
languages that you could try it from in
this case it says sepedi but that's not
the translation from sepedi
what does that mean what is going on
how did that get there in Google
Translate I don't know I'm not advancing
any Theory I'm not telling you that
there's some Grand conspiracy of
of evil people meeting in a room at
Google but
it is kind of weird
and it's not just weird anymore as a
fluke you might it'd be hard to say well
that's just happen to answer
we've now seen it twice
Balenciaga do without ball and siaga
ball is the king
on top of this campaign that Balenciaga
has put out with
s m imagery you know chains and leather
and the weird pedo stuff and then you
look at the the stylists with Balenciaga
they post overt satanic imagery all over
the social media and it's I just I'm
trying to Rack my head I always want the
simplest solution the least kind of out
there's
explain that to me I can't I can't
really make sense of that once might be
a fluke twice I'm starting to see a
pattern here and it's a pattern that
crops up a lot not just in our modern
culture but it's cropped up a whole lot
throughout all of history
now speaking of fire when you want to
cook some nice stuff over a fire you
definitely need a propane tank when you
want the easiest way to replace your
propane tank you need cinch right now
head on over to cinch.com use promo code
Knowles the last thing you want to be
doing the morning of the Christmas party
is driving around to exchange your empty
propane tank for a new one get ahead of
the game this year with cinch cinch is a
propane grill tank Home Delivery Service
they deliver propane tanks right to your
door cinch delivers on your schedule no
long-term commitment or a subscription
required plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to be home to
receive the delivery you can track the
order on the Cinch app from anywhere
looking to exchange a tank cinch handles
the whole process for you so you don't
have to go to the hardware store or gas
station exchange any brand of tank as
long as it is standard Grill size choose
the delivery date cinch handles the rest
go online to cinch.com or download their
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just 10 bucks
with promo code Knolls go to cinch.com
or download the Cinch app and use promo
code nulls to get your first tank for
just 10 bucks cynch.com promo code nulls
this is a limited time offer you must
live with an essential service area to
redeem it cinch.com offer for details
speaking of dark stuff from powerful
people Disney CEO Bob Iger
has finally spoken out
on not only Disney's woke content that
they're putting out there for kids but
also the political campaign to pressure
Disney not to put out that woke content
and what you're seeing reported in some
conservative media is that Disney is
backing away from the culture War you
know Disney has learned its lesson and
it's going to back away and and no
longer push this woke content on kids
that's not exactly what I'm hearing from
Bob Iger
's a virtual question many cast members
had wished that Disney stayed out of
politics Will Disney stay out of making
political statements
you know I think there's a Mis
perception here about what politics is
and I think that some of the subjects
that have proven to be controversial as
it relates to Disney have been branded
political and I don't necessarily
believe they are I don't think when you
were telling stories and attempting to
be a good citizen of the world that
that's political
just not how I view it do I like the
company being embroiled in controversy
of course not it can be distracting and
it can have a negative impact on the
company and to the extent that I can
work to kind of quiet things down I'm
going to do that but I think it's it's
important to put in perspective what
some of these subjects are and not just
simply brand them political
so the way this is being reported again
an example from Chris Ruffo who's done
excellent work fighting a CRT exposing
all the crazy indoctrination of kids he
says exclusive I've obtained video from
Bob iger's first town hall with
employees in which he signals that he
will work to quiet things down
politically and move toward neutrality
in the culture War I agree with Chris
Ruffo on most things many many things
but I don't agree with his
analysis of what Bob Iger just said I
sort of think it's the opposite I think
what Bob Iger is saying is yeah I want
to quiet things down because I don't
want Disney's bottom line to get hurt
but I am not going to back away from the
culture War you heard what he said there
he said
uh listen certain things are being
described as political that I don't
think is are political at all such as
trying to be a good citizen of the world
first of all
anytime
you discuss citizenship You Are by
definition discussing something that is
political if citizenship is not
political nothing is political to be a
citizen is to be a member of a political
community so Bob Iger is either ignorant
of what politics is or he's being obtuse
there but to use that phrase citizen of
the world that's an extremely
politically loaded phrase to be a
citizen of the world
is is in conflict with being a citizen
of a Nation to be a citizen of the world
is to accept globalism which is one of
the most politically controversial
concepts of our age
and it's obviously Disney is leaning far
more in that direction and against the
nationalists so I I would that it were
so simple but I don't think that Disney
has learned anything I don't think that
Disney is
backing away from the culture where the
only thing that they've they have
learned there's one thing that they have
learned which is they've got to be a
little bit more subtle about it they
can't have their Executives out there on
camera saying we're going to push a not
so secret gay agenda no no they need a
secret agenda they need their their
radical agenda needs to be a little bit
subtler so it doesn't arouse the ire of
the ordinary American people to such a
point that you've got governors in
different states Ron DeSantis in
particular going in and punishing Disney
for pushing this kind of content okay
and that is why Disney feels that
they've got to make any changes
whatsoever it is because of Ron DeSantis
and Rhonda santis is taking a Victory
lap for that win
we didn't drag them in Tucker they went
in on their own and not only opposed the
bill they threatened to get it repealed
these are parents rights important
policies in our state that are very
popular and so they brought this on
themselves all we did was stand up for
what's right and yes they're a big
powerful company but you know what we
stand up for our folks and I don't care
what a burbank-based California company
says about our laws
now don't forget everyone is celebrating
what DeSantis did now but at the time it
was somewhat controversial on the right
you you had people on the right who are
more uh used to that kind of libertarian
language or the supposed neutrality of
the kind of bush era nice nice
neoconservative uh talking points uh the
people who say we never want to use the
government if we use the government that
makes us no different from the left the
kind of people who say I'm just going to
throw my hands in the air and go live my
own life
those are the people who said no
DeSantis is overreaching he's an
authoritarian he's a fascist he can't
tell Disney to stop transiting the kids
then you had then you had the
conservatives on the other hand can you
tell which side of this battle I'm on
then you had the conservatives on the
other hand who were saying this is
awesome good job keep it up to santis
wield the political institutions to
bring Disney into line that is what the
people want you to do
you not only have a right to do that as
governor of Florida you have an
obligation to do that good job keep it
up and though that was controversial at
the time you could see very clearly Ron
DeSantis leaning into the conservative
side more than the libertarian said and
he's going to keep doing it Ron DeSantis
says he's going to keep going there has
been a threat in recent days that Apple
might kick Twitter out of the app store
because Elon Musk is allowing
conservatives to speak on Twitter again
and this is simply unacceptable so Apple
says okay maybe we're going to get rid
of of Twitter if if Apple and Android
did that Twitter would basically just
disappear it would not exist because
those two companies own the smartphone
market
Rhonda Santa says if Apple kicks Twitter
out of the App Store
we should take Anti-Trust action and
bust them up
we did Big Tech censorship Bill two
years ago it's gotten caught up in the
courts I think the U.S Supreme Court's
going to accept that case for this term
Texas has a similar case there's a
conflict in the circuits and so whatever
the states can do to protect people's
rights to engage in free expression and
you know what some of these companies do
they get a lot of benefits from the
government as you said Pat and things
like that the social media companies get
liability protection and yet they turn
around and they use that protection to
marginalize voices they disagree with so
I think from the Congressional
perspective though they need to look at
antitrust with these massive companies
because they are exercising massive
amounts of power over our society
so the most interesting political battle
here is not the right versus the left
you know the right wing Ron DeSantis
versus the left-wing Apple the most
interesting battle the most
controversial aspect of this is the
right versus the right the most
interesting battle here is the
libertarian point of view versus the
conservative point of view the
libertarian point of view which is well
you don't like what Apple's doing build
your own Apple build your own Twitter
versus the conservative point of view
now we're going to bring you guys into
line you you woke corporations are
selling out our political order you are
doing things that are deeply wrong and
unjust and we're going to wield
political power to bring you back into
line and Ron DeSantis is siding with the
conservatives it's it's the battle
between
politics is Downstream of culture
and
the law is a teacher okay because
politics is Downstream of culture is is
true in as much as it's true yeah it's
true that the movies affect the
political order in fact that's why we're
all so concerned about what Disney is
doing
but the way that that phrase has been
used has basically been as a way to let
Republican politicians off the hook to
say that you know Politics the
government is not how we should solve
any of our problems we should only make
movies we should only engage in the
cultural battles and because it would be
so unjust to wield the government versus
the traditional view which is of course
course we should wield the government
why why else do we run for elections of
course the government can fix some
problems
of course the law is a teacher
and we we should know that because
conservatives and Libertarians prattle
on all the time about how the government
creates certain incentives and that can
lead to bad outcomes we talk about how
in the 1960s the government created all
these perverse incentives with the rise
of the welfare state and all sorts of
terrible laws and that that led to bad
outcomes because those incentives
changed people's behavior well if the
government can create incentives that
make people's behavior worse the
government also can create incentives
that make people's behavior better of
course that's always been true of course
the law is a teacher and so what Rhonda
santis is saying is yeah we're gonna
okay you Movie Makers you go making
movies and you people in in the culture
Private Industry obviously you do you do
what you you do the best that you can
you fix the culture from your angle but
I'm going to wield the government okay
and 10 years ago I bet a lot of
conservatives and Republicans would not
have spoken like this or would not have
wanted to hear that kind of message but
this is a different time and I think
Rhonda scientist knows what time it is
in that regard
all right obviously the guy is he's
energetic he feels like he's going to be
running for president and that's that's
why when you want to feel energetic when
you want to feel ready to take on a
presidential campaign you gotta you
gotta take some coffee you got to drink
Black Rifle coffee right now go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code Knowles
Black Rifle coffee company is helping
you knock out your Christmas shopping
with a ton of fabulous new products this
year shop the best Brewing year
thermoses mugs and apparel designed for
folks who love country and coffee Black
Rifle sources the most exotic roasts
from around the globe all coffee is
roasted here in the U.S by veteran-led
teams of coffee experts stuff your
Christmas stockings with the latest
roasts from America's coffee for 10 off
with my code Knowles kwles better yet
sign your Secret Santa up for a coffee
Club subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need the most
it is the gift that keeps on giving
Black Rifle coffee is veteran founded
and operated they take pride in serving
coffee and culture to people who love
America every purchase you make with
Black Rifle helps support veteran and
first responder causes go to
blackrafulcoffee.com use promo code
Knolls for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles for
10 off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee now Ron
DeSantis is not doing all of this
just to do it I'm sure he believes in
these things I'm sure he's got plenty of
principles he's obviously got a lot of
political courage he's also doing this
because the guy is clearly running for
president and the the clearest evidence
that he's running for president is that
he's about to publish an autobiography
and the autobiography is about his his
early life and his career in college and
playing college baseball and I believe
he was in the Navy and then Congress and
then now governor of Florida and so it's
it's a candidate book it's a book to
introduce himself to the American people
who don't yet know him
and it has a title like all of the other
candidate books this title is called the
courage to be free
Florida's blueprint for America's
Revival
and then on the cover it's just Ron
DeSantis standing in front of American
flag smiling it's just it is the most
archetypal
candidate running for president book
that you have ever seen in your whole
life so if you were a Gambling Man right
now certainly you would bet that Ryan
DeSantis is running it doesn't
necessarily mean he's running sometimes
candidates have come out with these
books or potential candidates have come
out with these books and then they
choose not to run classic example of
this would be 2012 Mitch Daniels then
the governor of Indiana
really looked like he was going to run
for president I was actually somewhat
involved in his
Proto pre-campaign for president and he
had this book coming out saving the
republic or keeping the Republic and it
was a total candidate book and then he
ended up not running because he
didn't want to deal with certain family
issues if he went on the campaign and it
was all very sad but he still had the
book come out because he was preparing
the campaign and you see all of these I
remember Tim pawlenty when he was
running for president he came out with a
book it was called the courage to stand
it was one of the stupidest Idols I've
ever heard does it really require a lot
of courage to stand
I suppose it requires more courage than
to sit
your at least requires more strength but
the courage to stand wow that's amazing
and uh now DeSantis the courage to be
free okay slightly better titled but
still it's just totally typical of the
genre so what does this tell us
it tells us he's probably running for
president but what it tells us is
something about the campaign that he
intends to run for president
Ron DeSantis
by all markers intends to run a
conventional campaign for president
compare the books
the courage to be free Florida's
blueprint for America right even to say
here's my blueprint for the whole
country is to say I'm going to run for
president
compared to Donald Trump's candidate
book he put out a candidate book too in
2016. but it wasn't called the courage
to stand keeping the Republic the
courage to be free it it was called
crippled America crippled America how to
make America great again every other
candidate book in all of human history
has had some really positive Rosy happy
title trumps has this really negative
title crippled America is really bad but
we're gonna make it great again every
candidate book in all of history has the
candidates there smiling in front of an
American flag right on the cover of the
book Trump's cover was him just looking
really angrily at the reader so there's
furrowed brow classic Apprentice Trump
expression Trump ran an unconventional
campaign
most campaigns they open up with the
candidate you know standing in front of
the Statue of Liberty or something like
that and saying our best days are ahead
we it's going to be a bright and sunny
future when you're like me Trump's
campaign opens up with him coming down
the escalator in his own building saying
that the country is being flooded by
rapists and murderers and maybe some
good people but America's going to hell
in a handbasket but he's going to fix it
okay that was an unconventional campaign
and I I'm I don't mean this as a
criticism of of DeSantis or the DeSantis
team I'm sure this is strategic I don't
think that they're just stumbling
blindly into this
this is showing you the difference
that the way that that DeSantis is going
to try to distinguish himself from Trump
I've said from the beginning the
challenge for DeSantis is that his
finest selling point is that he's
supposed to be Trump 2.0 Trump with all
the upsides none of the downsides
but his place in the campaign is as the
anti-trump candidate
so his place in the campaign is because
Donald Trump is running
is going to attract all of the squishes
and the libs and the moderates and the
Never trumpers right that's not to
Santa's fault that's just the way the
circumstances are and so how does he
thread that needle well right now what
he's trying to do is he's trying to be
super duper trumpy when it comes to
pummeling private corporations into
submission which is a good thing that's
great that distinguished Trump from the
rest of the Republicans who would just
spout off some platitude about free
trade and then you know build your own
Twitter and then go on doing nothing so
Trump said no we're going to bring these
companies into line okay we're gonna
wield the government to make you
companies do what we want and so
DeSantis is going very very trumpy on
that front but then he's running the
opposite of a trump campaign on the
other he's running the classic just here
I am a nice smiling American Boy with
some platitude as the title of my book
and so that is going to distinguish it
again it's a very very
tough balancing act that DeSantis is is
going to have to do but
not to take my Nostradamus hat out here
I think that is very clearly the
strategy that they are undertaking and
so far it's been very very effective
speaking of politicians writing about
themselves
this is my absolute favorite news story
of I don't know the past year this is so
so funny
there's a state senator in California
Democrat by the name of Scott weiner if
if you've heard that name before it is
in the context of Scott weiner uh
pushing a bill which then did did become
law
to give more lenient punishments to
pederasts
to men who sexually abuse minors to to
make it such that they're more likely to
get lenient sentences
and his name is Scott Weiner and that's
just amazing
so Scott weiner has just come out and he
he said
not even 24 hours after magrifter
Charlie Kirk tweeted homophobic lies
about me I received this threat
repeating one of his lies and that was
the point riling people up against me
and other lgbtq people words have
consequences and Twitter is becoming a
cesspool for this crap first of all
pretty amazing that this guy is lumping
in
pedos and and pedo supporters with lgbtq
I mean is that not in itself a bit
homophobic wouldn't you say state
senator weiner uh but here's what he
says he received
after that awful Charlie Kirk told
terrible lies about him this is the
threat that he received and he includes
just a screenshot of it
it's a shame you come out and you're
okay to release all these pedophiles
you're okay with people intentionally
giving other people AIDS and your office
can't even pick up the phone to answer
about these questions you're sick man I
don't even call you you shouldn't even
be a man you're sick individual I don't
care about what you do off hours but
once when you try to force it upon
California it's like myself and others
you'll have something coming to you
people like you won't be able to walk
down the streets when light comes to the
darkness that you're effing providing
you piece of s-h-i-t
wow man that's a threat that is it
that's a real threat that's not good to
threaten people
except there was something a little bit
weird about this screenshot of the
message that Scott weiner allegedly
received
it has a cursor right at the end of it
now
the cursor is the thing that you see
when you type something on the computer
you know it's just that blinking line
when you are writing a Word document or
a note
so I've just got a little bit of a pro
tip for Scott weiner
when when you are fabricating a threat
against yourself
it is really smart to remove your cursor
from the screenshot before you post it
to Twitter I'm amazed that at the end of
this threat
the the uh would be assailant didn't say
this is Maga country
give me your Subway sandwich Senator
weiner Senator weiner have you ever been
on the show Empire
it it's so the guy just totally got
exposed
and now we cover this on the show a lot
when these
hate crime threat homophobic racist
sexist when these when these things make
it into the news
a lot of the time maybe most of the time
they turn out to be hoaxes they turn out
to be Jesse Smollett situations and that
would seem to be what's going on here so
I wasn't the only guy to notice this
number of other people did too and then
sometime later
Scott weiner had to answer this and so
he said
and for all the Maga conspiracy
theorists out there the threat was a
voicemail
and this is a transcription but have fun
spinning around with your conspiracies
anything has a little eye rolling emoji
oh hold on see
you you told us initially that you got
this this threat
and then he posted the screenshot
which had the cursor I forgot to mention
the threat also had little uh spell
check lines underneath it because the
grammar was off so you want to turn that
off too when you when you fabricate your
own threats but now he's he's saying no
no it actually wasn't an email or a text
or anything it was a voicemail but that
I I transcribed but if it was a
voicemail why wouldn't why wouldn't you
just post the audio
you could post that to Twitter that'd be
very easy in fact it would it would be
much more engaging if there were a
little sort of video screen with the
with the audio playing and you could you
could hear this guy and probably make it
easier to identify the man who's making
this threat this awful terrible Maga
right-wing conservative who
almost certainly does not exist right
I think probably if if he did post the
audio which does not exist of this which
almost certainly doesn't exist it would
probably sound like that Nigerian guy
who was who is uh paid to attack Jesse
Smollett in Chicago
doesn't hold up does not hold up I think
Senator Scott weiner
should take the L
anybody
any reasonable person would have to say
this is most likely
almost certainly a
hoax a threat perpetrated fabricated by
Scott weiner upon himself and you should
just take the L and move on bro just
take the L move on this this response
that he gave later after we noticed his
cursor in the spell check lines is
almost as bad as my Twitter was hacked
no one ever symbolitician actually wow
oh my gosh when
when Anthony Weiner got caught sending
weird sexual photos of himself to people
on Twitter and he meant to privately
message them but he publicly messaged
them what was his excuses excuses well
my Twitter got hacked this is almost as
bad as an excuse as my Twitter got
hacked I don't don't believe it buddy
sorry
no we're we're going to continue to
criticize you and other politicians who
openly Advocate being lenient to
pederasts to pedophiles broadly
sorry buddy sorry I hope you held on to
your Subway sandwich
of giving
officially upon us as you shop holiday
gifts and Deals you should ask yourself
who exactly are you giving to
because if you're buying stocking
stuffers from woke companies you're just
stuffing the pockets of leftist CEOs and
paying for them to mock what you believe
in don't give them your money give
Jeremy your money
his brand
brand new his brand and brand new
collection of Jeremy's razors products
will make the perfect gift for the
pronoun less men in your life well I
mean those men have pronouns they're
just the correct pronouns today is the
last day of his 30 off cyber sale get
your loved ones some woke free shampoo
and conditioner body wash and beard kit
or the new Precision 5 razor with flip
back trimmer before Jeremy merrily
restores list pricing go to
jeremy'sraisers.com today for your last
chance to save
speaking of California there's more
there's more trouble coming out of
California
co-board of Supervisors has just
approved the police use of Killer Robots
remote controlled robots armed with
deadly explosives can now be used by
public officials in California
and I gotta tell you
I don't really care
it's fine I actually don't have a
problem with this I know a lot of
conservatives are going to say this is
horrible oh my gosh that you're going to
let the police use these Killer Robots
yes you're going to let the state have
these Killer Robots uh yes we already
give the state the power to use all
sorts of weapons
that they could turn on us if they want
to that's called having a police force
that's called having a functioning
government
I I think the the robots are a pretty
good idea because what what are they
going to be used for first of all there
are there are some checks in place such
that they need to be authorized
by a small small number of people who
will be held accountable one hopes uh if
the the robots are misused but I don't
think these robots are just going to be
patrolling the streets uh strafing us
all down with machine guns not yet
that's not until they develop
Consciousness on their own and then they
take over like in Terminator but if
they're just being used by remote
controls right now then it's no
different than a drone it's no different
than any other kind of technological
advancement in Weaponry what are they
going to be used for they're not going
to be used for people who go jaywalking
they're going to be used to go into very
very dangerous places that you see in
San Francisco these are these are going
to be used to go go into trap houses to
go to go get very serious gangsters and
criminals and drug traffickers and all
the rest and the reason that that
they're going to do it is so that some
poor cop doesn't need to be the first
guy in the door
right and so uh there are there are
questions about the implementation
and there need to be safeguards and they
need to implement this slowly if they're
going to implement it at all they need
to make sure that there aren't going to
be catastrophic errors where some robot
ends up blowing up an innocent person's
home or something like that but if we're
talking about a very very limited use of
these Killer Robots to go into places
where we know it's gang territory where
we know that it's very very dangerous we
got cop killers in there who are going
to kill the poor guy who goes in first
then I'm I have no problem sending in a
robot to blow these guys up I have no
problem at all being a cop is a very
very hard job and there are there are
bad cops sure but most cops are good
guys and there are there is a risk of
the political Authority overstepping its
bounds but we need to have political
authorities we're called upon to respect
the political Authority and when they
when they go bad we need to exercise
political control over them I've really
got no no problem with this at all I
know this will put me in the minority of
conservatives but
I listen I'm I'm anti-crime okay and
I've been consistently anti-crime and
conservatives used to be anti-crime and
then there was this period during the
Trump era when all the conservatives
started sounding like AOC and they
cheered Trump on for do you remember the
first step act which was the jailbreak
bill for drug traffickers and dealers
and it was it was presented as this bill
to just let the poor guy who was picked
up for a dime bag of marijuana those
guys statistically do not exist the
people who go to jail for drugs go to
jail for peddling drugs for drug
trafficking this during the the worst uh
drug crisis in our entire country this
opioid epidemic and you're gonna let
them out of prison I think that's
completely insane so I I stood for him
then even though it was an unpopular
position then conservatives became tough
on crime again
and then
now they sometimes go I don't know they
go back and forth a little bit following
the wins but no that's good we should be
tough on crime remember when Biden was
running
and some conservatives opportunistically
attacked Biden for his 1994 crime Bill
1994 crime bill is like the only good
thing Biden's ever done in public life
that was a good bill okay so we did we
shouldn't Blow In The Wind we shouldn't
just take a cheap shot at San Francisco
when it's easy to do so it is good to be
tough on crime
there are risks man we got to mitigate
those risks and we got to be prudent now
speaking of potential tyrannical
government
Corrine Jean-Pierre spokesman for the
president will not say whether or not
the White House would be willing to try
to shut Twitter down as the White House
has suggested in recent days
when you say that you're going to be
monitoring some of the speech on there
if you see something that you don't like
would you try to shut Twitter down so
look you know when you when you talk
about monitoring you know it is uh I I
hate to break it to you Peter just like
everybody else we very much monitor the
news we pay close attention to
everything that you all are reporting
and and Twitter's in the news a lot and
so that's what we're paying attention to
we're paying attention to what is in the
news and what is being reported on uh on
the misinformation that's out there
let's not forget there's groups like
NAACP the Anti-Defamation League and the
public health leaders have been very
vocal about their concerns as well so
yes we are reading what you all are are
writing and and looking at what you all
are reporting about the misinformation
that is out there but you know I would
hope that all Americans uh including
social media companies civil rights
organizations I just laid out including
Fox as well will agree that we need to
uh you know we need to uh to uh you know
call out hate speech and misinformation
that's a whole lot of words to say the
White House might try to shut down
Twitter
for allowing conservatives to speak on
there that's a whole lot of words to say
it but that's what she's saying it's a
simple question
you guys have talked about how you're
monitoring Twitter because now Twitter
is is allowing conservatives to speak
more freely are you willing to shut it
down
well you know I mean look we gotta look
we got to look at things and maybe you
know look that's a nice Twitter you got
there sure it would be ashamed if
something happened to it
so I don't the reason I mention this I'm
not surprised at all that the Democrats
are willing to wield the government to
shut down conservatives from having a
voice in the Public Square
but I don't want to hear peep from
Democrats on the authoritarian overreach
of Ron DeSantis going after Disney the
White House is threatening to shut down
Twitter if it allows conservatives to
have a voice in the Public Square I
don't want to hear anything about
wielding the government against the
private corporations give me a break the
Democrats have been doing that since
forever and they continue to do it today
in a much more aggressive way than the
conservatives do I don't want to hear it
well no but it's to stop hate speech oh
yeah hate speech by which the Democrats
mean uh speech that they don't like by
which the Democrats mean any speech from
any conservative ever speaking of hate
speech there is a story
that that drove me up a wall
this is a story from the motherland out
there in the United Kingdom it's about a
woman who has worked in in the court for
many many years 83 years old lady in
waiting to the late Queen Elizabeth
godmother to Prince William
and uh Buckingham Palace was hosting an
event for this charity and uh so this
woman shows up to the charity and uh
Prince William's godmother this nice
British aristocratic lady says where are
you from
and the woman at the charity says sister
space the woman's name is negozi Fulani
she's a black lady which is a crucial
detail for this story because where are
you from she says sister space
no where'd you come from We're based in
Hackney no what part of Africa are you
from I don't know they don't leave any
records it's a funny answer well you
must know where you're from I spent time
in France where are you from here the UK
no but what nationality are you I am
born here and am British no but where do
you really come from where do your
people come from my people lady what is
this oh I can see I'm going to have a
challenge getting you to say where
you're from when did you first come here
lady I'm a British national my parents
came here in the 50s when oh I knew we'd
get there in the end your Caribbean no
lady I'm of African Heritage Caribbean
descent and British nationality oh so
you're from and so this is allegedly how
the conversation went according to the
charity lady
uh and let's just take her word for it
this is verbatim how the conversation
went
this woman the charity lady
whined and complained and made a big
fuss about this the the poor woman the
Godmother to Prince William has been
fired for the the spokesman for Prince
William made a statement said racism has
no place in our society the comments
were unacceptable and it is right that
the individual has stepped aside with
immediate effect this is Lady Hussey
who's 83 years old are you kidding me
are you freaking kidding me there was
nothing wrong with those comments
yes is the phrasing a little weird yes
did this older woman
pester this charity lady with a question
that she didn't want to answer yes sure
have you ever talked to an 83 year old
do 80 do is it not the case that all 83
year olds
sometimes speak in a strange way and
pester you with questions that you don't
want to answer there is nothing wrong
with asking somebody what's your
background
there's nothing wrong with that at all
people ask me frequently oh Michael
where what's your where's your family
from what do you do what's your back
you're from Sicily yeah yeah I'm from
half I'm half from Sicily and then half
from the British Isles and oh yeah it's
where in Sicily this is something we ask
people all the time there's nothing
wrong with it
I'm British lady no she's asking you
your background because you're obviously
not English you're the the English are a
people there are there are people who
look a certain way and you don't look
that way because your family came here
as immigrants which is fine the British
invited your family to come here as
immigrants she's asking a perfectly
polite question of what's your
background and she actually
got the answer out of you finally which
is oh my family background is from the
Caribbean
you know Africa by way of the Caribbean
into Britain
furthermore the way you know that this
is not a question that ought to be off
limits
is because the libs tell us how
important your racial background is
right out of the one side of their
mouths the libs tell us there is pretty
much nothing more important to your
identity than your race than your
ethnicity then your nationality then
Blackness and oh it's so Blackness is it
the heart of the experience of anybody
with even slightly dark skin
but on the other hand how dare you ask
me this race doesn't matter at all
ethnicity doesn't matter at all
nationality doesn't matter at all how
dare you lady Hussey ask that question
it's just totally incoherent it's
totally cynical and opportunistic I feel
terrible for this woman I think it was
extremely cowardly of the court court to
fire this woman godmother to the Future
King and uh you know long time Aid and
Confidant of the late Queen all because
this obvious political leftist activist
with a chip on her shoulder can't show a
little bit of Grace to an elderly woman
who asked a perfectly fine question in a
way that may have been a bit petulant or
or poorly worded but a question that we
all know deep down is not in any way
mean or cruel or offensive completely
Preposterous and I really wish people
would stop caving into these cynical
games of the libs whether we're talking
about people here in America or the
Future King of England
speaking of political leadership
I've got my friend Alan Estrin
founder of Prager University coming on
the show because Alan has
probably the best take that I have heard
on Trump
and 2022 and 2024 and Alan has marvelous
takes on so very many things Alan was
actually the I don't know that I've
mentioned this on air before Alan was
The crucial figure in getting me to
write speechless
Alan more than basically anybody is
responsible for my book speechless and
he's got a great take on on Trump so the
show continues now that's going to be in
the member block if you are not a member
what's wrong with you come on don't just
be part of the Hawaii paloi join the
elite the
Inner Circle here at the daily wire
click the description
uh and join us
[Music]
foreign